ladies gentlemen here we are once again
week to week and here is yo
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah so I got mr. ryan hollins on the
show he was ex-nba player he's actually
a great sports talk show analyst you see
him on debate shows all the time he's
been on First Take many times I always
see him at the Clipper game I think he's
I think he works you know in ESPN he's
like specifically with the Clippers but
I'm not sure I don't even know if I even
talked to him about that but you know
he's it's actually we have a very
interesting conversation about the
Michael Jordan documentary about the
state of the NBA about his journey in
the NBA about sports about LeBrons
legacy Jordan his legacy I'm super into
sports so it's great to have somebody
like this on the show so I hope you guys
enjoy it I'm continuing to put out the
content also if you enjoy gaming make
sure you watch me on Erik Griffin gaming
I'm on twitch and YouTube I go live on
Twitch occasionally live on YouTube but
mostly on Twitter's and I put post
videos on YouTube but anyway look for me
Erik Griffin gaming but I'm excited to
play this episode for you I really enjoy
this dude like I say he talks a lot of
smack on Twitter he's super into sports
I mean he was a competitive high level
NBA basketball player so that carries
over into other areas of his life and we
talked about that too so please enjoy
this episode of riffing with Griffin
with mr. ryan hollins thank you ladies
on the welcome to the program mr. ryan
hollins been all more beans in kendall
Jenner
you know yeah you know what I really
wish you had on one of your suits that's
what I really wish you Hanna listen
brother I listening then but I hear an
opportunity
brother this visit you do that home
right now just get dressed with no
reason man oh man so I mean yeah I mean
I you know we're like a couple months in
now to this quarantine so I can I could
just imagine how it is for you but like
in terms of like sports how are you
managing you know is are you really
feeling it because you were you know you
were an athlete you know you were
working in sports for so yeah you've
actually I think you've worked more as a
reporter now but you've been out of the
league that long right well ha or it's
getting equal yeah uh it's been about
four years for me and I would say like
the biggest thing that I missed
ultimately is just the games and I'll be
honest bro like we all took it for
granted I will take a little hiatus
season to be back you know you saw the
bra I made a comments like no fans I'm
not playing like you know so I just
think that all that is coming into
account and you know we're really
starting to fill it and I would say like
me being retired it's not hitting me as
hard as I can only imagine these current
athletes you got to think man your
entire life work like clockwork right
it's you know hey season starts in
October or whatever we train in the
summers you know we take a little bit of
right after the season to get going and
you kind of do that year round so for a
lot of these guys it was kind of fun for
a second like oh I'm on vacation and
then it was like well hold on man this
thing isn't letting up so I could I can
definitely see the frustration you know
sitting in with some of these young kids
and for myself you know there's only so
much ex-boxer you know I can play right
now yeah I feel you on that and you know
I think to is like I always think about
like for a professional athlete it's
like you play you're you're a
professional
from 22 like I don't know maybe the
average is like 34 you know what I mean
and then but as a 34 year old man to be
retired it's like that's already
difficult enough as it is to be taken
away from that limelight to be taken
away from that mug in the competition
and then you know now you're like have
to have like a regular life I mean
that's hard enough for people isn't it
you know Eric that the biggest
transition for me was being competitive
and I got to play ten years in the
league so there was a little bit of a
letdown time where you you know you
start to know like hey man I only got a
year or two left or shoot these
contracts ain't coming in the same way
you kind of acclimate yourself to it but
ultimately what what ends up getting us
I would say the biggest difference is
you had this competitive edge in you
that I don't even know if you realize
that it starts going away and you know
it's like it's the biggest how to put it
as an athlete you always have this
nervous feeling so like I would before I
will go to the gym I was ingrained to
feel like somebody else is in the gym
training you don't go to the gym
this guy's gonna pass you up where hey
you're not running sprints this guy's
gonna run by you in the game or you know
you're not gonna be able to keep up and
practice I always had this nervous
feeling like I would wake up out of the
cold nap and feel like I was late to
shoot around or like late to like a team
meeting and have that dream all the time
day three buddy at all and I got up
squirming around so you just had that
feeling or even like just in everyday
life like you know we'll be having a
conversation and I got to win the
conversation you're still like that
though on ESPN I noticed that about oh
absolutely yeah if you know it's not a
knock I'm just really is that that's
part of your competitive nature right it
as I when I would I would go on first
sake or the debate show or something to
that matter I'm going to compete I'm
going to win and you know what's funny
for me I get some of my fix some of my
competitive fix by doing that and that
spilled my time
to compete on that end rather than on in
the physical end and I you know I'll
give you a story where I realize like it
jumped out of me a bit so I don't really
play pick-up basketball cuz I'm seven
feet and it's hard for big guys to fight
other big guys and it just never really
works out everybody wants to go out the
pro but I needed to work out somehow and
at ESPN we were starting to play pick-up
basketball and I come out and I'm just
like let's have fun it's cool let me
just be the guy standing here and I'll
pass everybody the ball and I won't
really play and you know the scores like
seven eight whatever they're playing you
know I'm jumpers and then I just take
the ball shoot an elbow you know elbow
guy turn and go up and you know we win
the game so that continues to progress
and next thing you know I'm getting a
little more shape and a little more
shape and teams don't like to lose so
what they start to do is they start to
stack their teams against me so that the
next thing you know II I'm in this
competitive warfare with these guys this
strategy this like playoff strategy with
them Dan Ryan rules yeah absolutely it
would be eight guys in the paint I would
get the basketball my teammate will have
the ball and about you're just not gonna
garden like they just it was like a like
a four-man zone so I was alright I got
to do more and you know I continued to
win and what happened was one time I
went to go up and a guy he just he just
clobbered me and I I didn't really in I
Connor I can't remember I shot a male
born I probably you Eric you see you sir
oh my god probably shot a male but
without even knowing without even know
what oh I just start you know I don't
cuss Eric but I just started laying into
the champ y'all keep grabbing me like
that baba blind everybody like to me
jumped out like all right you don't want
to see what's on a minute like you know
we start
in but like when two athletes speak like
that to each other it's time to compete
when two regular people talk like that
it's a faint normally coming up yeah and
I had to like and everybody got so
scared and I had to jump back and go
this is not what that is man you got to
calm down a little bit but I'm used to
okay you elbow me I'm coming back with
the elbow over the top and now I'm a
jump hook you a rebound or darken or I'm
gonna you I'm going through your chest
you know what I'm saying it now I'm
throwing like a guy seven-foot tall
hitting you even if you're 65 that's a
different type of punishment but when
the guys six foot five is leaning on you
with everything he has that's still a
grown man so that's why I had that I was
think that was a moment I had to say
competitively hey do I want to be that
guy again at least even in pickup
basketball and where is it gonna leave
is it worth it now you never wanted to
you never had thoughts to play in the
big three to keep to get that itch to
play with other no I do I do and I
played the last you know that's
intriguing something play the last two
years
apparel I didn't know that I didn't do
too well you know if I do I don't watch
it that's the thing if I watch it I
would have known I just like cuz I'm a
snob in a way that I'm like I like the
highest form of whatever the sport you
guys showing I know you know for me like
I I like the NBA
I think the NBA is the highest form of
basketball and so when I watch even when
I watch the NCAA sometimes I'm like this
is a different game I mean it just it
just it looks different sometimes the
people that are excelling in it are
different than the types of players that
excel in the NBA it's like you know but
it's like that's a different mentality
and sometimes I get into and sometimes I
don't like around March Madness I'll get
into it cuz it brings out the
highest form of competition you know I
like the NBA just a low-key secrecy for
me what I'm hear from you and I'm not
you this isn't me break the I feel like
that's your competitive edge because
when you set a tone of being the best of
the best of everything that you do
that's the way you go and work see you
like I'm not you in our respect cuz it's
like I'm not trying to see the boys JB
get it on I want to see the best of the
best so you take that standard into the
workplace into everything you do you
haven't gold standard huh yeah I hear
that but you know what though it it
might be some of that but I'm really
talking about the actual what the sport
actually looks like at its highest level
because for instance hockey I can watch
any level of hockey because for some
reason is such a compelling engaging
sport when you're watching hockey
they're flying around and and then the
different levels don't look they look
the same
other than speed right but when with
basketball for some reason the less
athletic it doesn't look the same look
listen they jamming it the WNBA down I
throw it all the times and I have no
nothing against female sports but when
you look at the WNBA and you look at the
NBA it's like looking at two completely
different sports it's slower there's no
there's no flying up there's no Duncan
there's no you know II so for me this is
what I don't like you spoil yourself
yeah those who may not know you've got
those season tickets you're you're on
the floor yeah yeah and when you watch
NBA games on TV versus being on the
floor
it's probably like a drug you can't sit
because you're saying like dang LeBron
is a bad what like hold it looks--wait
like re like for instance I'll go up to
people all the time and they'll have
seen me on the first take of reality you
know whatever show or whatever and I'll
walk up on them and they almost jump
back in the first thing
say it is like man you're bigger than I
thought you were like what like huh like
paying translation and this is normally
like like like the guys the weekend
warriors Li yo this dude will put my but
this is what my behind and that's that's
like that's what I'm here you know
someone says it like that you really
care what me like you know I was talking
a lot about you today I said good night
but when you see ryan hollins standing
next to DeAndre Jordan but now you come
and see him next thing you know Larry
Joe and Mike at the arcade I like that
too when I when you you would walk by my
seats and I would be like tan that's a
lot of fabric you know I feel I know
exactly what you're saying up but I know
like you're I mean you're just you're
you're huge NBA fan not just player but
a fan you know and I know I listen I
follow you I follow the your Twitter I
followed all the artists with Perkins
and you know you know I'm with you on it
I know you have some strong opinions
about the NBA so let's talk about some
of these things like so you watching the
Jordan documentary yeah yeah I'm gonna
tell you what I've taken from it I
already was a Jordan fan I already I
already think he's larger than life but
this is even reinforcing it more getting
a little bit more inside about his
mentality how he played and how he
approached the game even in comparison
to his other teammates and I just can't
wait to see how much more we learn about
him but I know you're a big I know
you're a LeBron is the goat guy but like
after watching that is it changing your
mind at all in a weird way it's actually
reinforcing my feelings about LeBron
being a goat but I will say in terms of
Mike I hate for one I hate that anyone
thinks I don't like Michael Jordan
I have spot and own more Jordans like I
have ELISA
I have I have put one of his kids
through school okay with my little with
my little payments to Jordan Brand and
Michael was on my wall as a kid we used
to watch come fly with me you know em
like every day after school and then
going to back yard and go as a little
one and try to emulate it on it on the
tape I don't know if these kids know
what tapes are we actually had to
program in there these black things that
don't have those I stood there was like
three or four good one remember that one
word that one we're like he's talking
about was they come fly me when Michael
Jackson was on it for real and that's
and you watched it over and over like
that's what u're you could be a
different type of megastar in that time
okay neither here nor there but the one
thing I appreciate when I'm looking at
Michael and I look at Kobe you know
unfortunately with this passing we got
to learn so much more yeah they had a
standard that didn't go away so whether
it was Dean Smith Doug Collins Phil
Jackson Doug Collins again Michael
Jordan competed to win basketball games
everything else came second even to the
point his competitiveness was almost a
detriment he had to be saved from
himself yeah and I respect that because
he is who he is Michael Jordan went out
to like they're even more stories coming
up he was like the guy wanted to win ten
out of ten times and he would not stop
Horace Grant was actually telling the
story cuz now I'm like researcher
Michael even more and Horace Grant was
telling a story of a guy he's so bad
horse said the man I can't remember his
name but essentially this guy was
supposed to be the first Harold miner
right maybe maybe Jordan it was before
you won't even remember this guy I gotta
go find a doctor me to find this guy's
name and it was the interview Horace
Grant did the dew drops 38 on Mike after
the game Mike don't talk to nobody
mike is Sylar
he goes back to the hotel they get you
around the next day Mike is completely
stoic this is at the time where the NBA
will play those time back-to-backs where
you played the same team twice it was
almost like Chile travel like Yale where
it's just cheaper play the Celtics three
or four times in a row whatever it was
Michael Jordan played this guy the next
day Michael had 40 points at halftime so
but this is what I'm saying no but but
doesn't but what I'm saying to you
though is that I I don't think that
LeBron has had that in his career and I
think that you know how you say that
Michael's competitiveness he needed to
be saved yeah yeah I think
LeBron's never had someone to save him
from his lack of getting to that you
know and I think that his crew I think
when we look at the totality of the
Bronx career at the end of his career
he's had time to retire we're gonna look
back and be like damn he could have done
more
I mean like I think that because I
listen I'm one of these people that
there is a legitimate argument for
anybody to say LeBron is the greatest
basketball player to ever live he's
actually in the conversation literally
the only person in the conversation I
feel you know him it's like I'm saying
when you talk about Michael but I think
that Kareem you got a look at cream he's
just a victim of being all like from a
different era
but what dream did was fantastic but
he's like it's a big man sport you don't
I mean you know so you go okay boom and
and I believe that a center is only good
as the people that can get them the ball
you know I mean and that's the only
thing that's the only reason Kareem
isn't the go that's right that's the
only way he needs teammates with these
other guys you don't need teammates okay
so so but I'm saying when I look back on
it I think he should have I think that
Pat let's say Pat Riley's coaching the
Heat maybe they win that first
championship and in against Dallas maybe
they maybe they win four in a row in in
Miami and he doesn't leave Miami you
know what I mean you know you know and
then we already get that rivalry
with Golden State Warriors early because
it would have been it was the next year
it would probably uh you know to me so
I'm just saying when I looked at Michael
Jordan he fully maximized his career and
and then anytime he wanted to be great
at something he became great at
something cuz people forget that stretch
where the point guard was out and he had
to play point guard and for like 12
games he averaged a triple-double you
know it's like that's a kind of game he
had he had a 48 inch vertical you know
he was a physical specimen so what I'm
saying is I look at this documentary and
I go damn that dude was for sure to go
you know what I mean what see this is
what I look at and this is a big
difference so I give you for a story you
know my dad for instance well my dad
wanted to get something you know he work
you know over time my dad this is back
in the day before the regulations my dad
would go to work for three days straight
sometimes to put food on the table and
his job was almost set up to where if he
didn't work overtime we didn't really
make money he would make bad money so
when over time came he was like good
like it what they would double the pay
and it was almost set up to her he had
he had to take all the overtime you can
get at the same time with him doing all
that we were supposed to put a carport
in our backyard you know my dad did with
his bare hands got all the supplies
built a carport in the backyard the roof
was caving in
my dad would his bare hands gets up
there and fixes the roof you know what
I'm saying
Wow that Michael Jordan mentality was
you go to work put your hard hat on each
and every day as my dad got up in age
there was still projects around the
house for myself but I started do I got
some NBA money and you know in my mind I
never saw my money I never looked at it
and I mean saw it is then I wasn't like
man I got a million dollars of $300,000
it was just like keep living you're
saying life and keep going because
$300,000 at that time I made three
hundred thousand but the first thing I
did is I started to repair my parents
house my dad started to realize that
there are more ways to achieve the same
goal without killing yourself in
process mm-hm and then my dad started to
outsource some things and realize oh I
could budget this I can get that you
know I can get the the driveway paved
without breaking my back trying to do it
but that was his mentality I had to
change I bring that up because Michael
sure you going with it I feel like
Michael comes from the era of you broke
your back to get where you had to go
people don't know or may not remember
Larry Bird retired because he was paving
his mother's driveway his answers ain't
working was never the same
yeah later you may not have been a
millionaire I'm not sure what a
contractual situation was but somebody
woulda did that for free Larry do a
commercial for us but that was their
mom's in Indiana he coulda got that for
free do a commercial hey it's Larry Bird
welcome to Jim's idea yeah Jim's
painting service like but I bring that
up and I feel like LeBron James
understands I can get to the same goal
or the same destination with descent
with more longevity without killing
myself I hear you okay but what I'm
saying though in response to that though
is I think Jordan already had his impede
his moment of being like oh I don't have
to do everything before he won
championships that's what we already
said he had to readjust his game when
Phil Jackson came in and did that thing
that you did for your father
Phil Jackson did he came in and said we
but me love in the documentary where he
goes Paxson's open you know he was like
Paxson's Oakland dude give him the ball
and he was forceful about it Jordan says
that from his own mouth he was forceful
about it so Jordan was like okay that
game yeah 18 that game so I'm saying to
you the difference but the difference
between Jordan and LeBron is Jordan
figured it out and actually won what I'm
saying is look to go to the championship
eight times in a row you already in the
goat conversation in my opinion and what
I'm saying is we all know he wins all
eight we're going the bronze the
greatest ever
so you have to follow through with that
too and the follow through is winning
the championships and it's in it's his
own thing while he lost a lot of those
championships you know what I mean you
know like not in Cleveland we will get
into this discussion too by the way
because I think that what's happening
but we're gonna stay do what Kevin
Durant did was just it was selfish and I
think he regrets it you know he looks
back on I think he's gonna regret it you
know what I mean
and I think that's why I believe you
went to the Nets anyway but anyway the
point is he had no chance to get his
team's but LeBron is so great that we
were watching those to see if he could
do it I mean that's how great he is you
know but I'm saying is he still fell
short more times in succeed here this
though here it is you know hear this
though he we talk about circumstances
and I try to important I try to make my
space my stances off of what did you do
who are you as a player not so much your
circumstances I feel like the way was
paved for Michael Jordan to be Michael
Jordan and I feel like with less LeBron
has done more whoa why would I say that
because essentially Michael Jordan never
lost an NBA Finals six championships he
was the man everyone else was a role
player for one it was a different NBA
for two let's look at why I say the pate
the path was paid for Michael Jordan for
one you have an older brother that beats
the crap out of you every single day
LeBron didn't have an older brother
didn't have a dad okay let's move
forward Michael Jordan makes it to
college he plays for arguably one of the
greatest college coaches of all time
just behind John Wooden bull okay that's
the plus cuz Dean Smith is gonna teach
you three you got cooked you got players
you have greatness around you you got
guys like James James Worthy is a top 50
player all-time yeah
pulling you everything underrated what
people
I change whether you have completely
underrated player you know to declare
all time in college in college who you
surpass because top five small forward
you want to learn you know top five
small forward all you wanna you want to
learn you want to learn yeah big game
James fax he does get overlooked his
magic was shining cuz Kareem but
absolutely top five so then you get to
the NBA
okay things aren't great but you already
have that Dean Smith DNA of how to win
tie your shoes up come to compete you
know work every day next thing you do
you go from Phil Collins to scuse me
feel but listen then he gets Phil
Jackson and then he gets he gets
hand-picked or spoon-fed whatever and
this wasn't a guarantee the best
compliment that you can ever have to any
superstar scottie pippen you have the
guy you have one of 50 greatest players
of all time on your team that didn't
want the basketball that had no problem
playing defense in passing and scoring
when needed all game long how do you
find the top 50 greatest player that's
not a big man hold on he's another guard
he's actually taller than you Michael
that doesn't mind playing defense in
passing and doing those things
Scotty pity was the perfect complement
and Kendrick Perkins made the statement
I don't know if you saw the Gehrig I
know you play you saw everything he said
he he said Michael Jordan he said LeBron
James never had a player to palaver
Scottie Pippen now I disagree LeBron
James have better I think Dewayne Wade
in his own right has accomplished more
but I think I think to wane weight and
win a combination of Chris Bosh and Pat
Riley a sideline but listen but listen I
do agree LeBron's never had a guy to fit
him like that and I think LeBron finally
has his Scottie Pippen and a guy who
fits him perfectly but the only problem
is LeBron
on the other side of his career I'm talk
about Anthony Davis and I'm quoting yes
guys the truth he says yeah he's also a
kind of guy that can't do it on his own
exactly they're they're very very
similar so LeBron had to find Pat Riley
and Dwyane Wade to learn how to win at
that level
I give you an instance as great as
Cleveland was it is what they want to
put around LeBron and I think that
global tribe game and Gilbert tried his
best here's the truth there was no one
to teach LeBron how to be LeBron Michael
always had people that could teach him
how to be Michael he got to get beat up
by the Pistons you got to get beat up by
magic but that's what you say real quick
victim of circumstances like that's part
of what it is I mean there's a lot of
great players looking Kobe Bryant had a
great life he had he grew up rich he
grew he was a privileged kid and he had
the eye of the tiger so I don't know
what I'm saying is I believe LeBron has
that eye and he's one of those guys you
put I feel like you put him in Michael's
circumstances he does more and another
thing Erik was so glossed over to me and
I don't know if this just we're all
victims of three-point shooting and
dunks and scoring and he had 40 in the
fight he averaged like sometimes those
are bad shots Michael so you would shoot
your team out man but you know he was
gonna die fine LeBron James passing
ability get so gloss over no idea why
when we talk don't debate all week rent
we credit the hell out of Michael for
some scoring but when it comes at
LeBrons passing and what he does for the
team and the winning play you heard it
you brought up Michael didn't make the
winning plays until he was talk LeBron
always makes winning plays so I think
open sometimes you needed him to do the
other thing too I think he developed
that though Erik that's my thing I said
but what I'm saying is he's very proud
you just look you look I hear what
you're saying
you could take any player with like
tremendous skill and ability and say how
could we for
them into like the best player but
whatever their path was was their path
all we can deal with is the results and
all I'm saying to you is the results are
look this is what LeBron had over Jordan
he controls everything Jordan was the
lowest paid player on a lowest paid
superstar on his team he was like crazy
fourth highest paid player on his team
when he was the best player in the world
and it wasn't even close there was
nobody near him so I'm saying
LeBron's living in this era where he had
complete autonomy he controlled a lot of
his own destiny and that's where he got
in his own way that's what I'm saying
like I wish it's if we're talking about
where someone could be drafted I mean if
Kevin Garnett was drafted by San Antonio
he mean he'd be the greatest player ever
you know he'd be one of those kind of
guys so I'm saying you could do that all
day but all we could do is work out
worried about the circumstances of what
what what actually played out and like I
say I'm very close in saying that these
guys are very close you know but here's
the thing if we're picking teams let me
we're pick we're picking teams to do a
tournament we're picking we're picking
teams right let's say there's six of us
and we're all going like we're gonna
pick teams from the greatest players of
all time and they gonna play a one-off
tournament if I have the first pick and
I pick Jordan I'll take Jordan and the
number seven guy versus any other team
that's put that's gonna be put out there
because that's what you also have to
think about how somebody compliments and
brings the best out of the other players
around them Scotty Pittman wouldn't have
been the great player like that if it
wasn't for Michael Jordan Michael Jordan
made him that player
thanks thanks but this is where I also
leaned back towards the Brawn and I had
to ask myself see Michael Jordan get as
far as dominance those two don't compare
LeBron is not in the conversation with
Michael as far as dominance and
consistency
LeBron also plays in a different era I
feel like the NBA is not as physical but
it's more competitive but here's the
deal
Michael switch didn't turn on the Brawn
can do this and he's gonna have more
longevity at a higher level
then Michael Jordan will have ever had
because the committee player and wait
wait wait 19 points a game at 40 years
old was pretty good yeah but there were
horrible shots yeah we get it I love I
love Mike though okay by the way by the
way we don't know what he would have
done from 34 to when he came back I feel
like LeBron is gonna be winning
championships at that age and he and you
know what LeBron is also well Michael
was owner will shoot LeBron is gonna be
a better owner than my NBA owner the
most in general man well wait wait wait
I don't know you know but I say this
I'll say this dough you write LeBron I
mean Michael Jordan drafted Kwame Brown
you know what I'm saying as our owner I
mean we don't know but what I'm saying
is but as a businessman he still got a
ways to go I mean like oh yeah
listen the disparity between Jordan
Brand can err everybody else is like
there's a there's a B in that number
are we talking are we talking money made
or we talk about someone who really went
out and put in work cuz I feel like on
the business side LeBron is unparalleled
because he's found a way for one to work
with his friends that's yeah darn that's
impossible
I can't work with my friends okay we
like each other maybe an associate I
could work with someone I can't like we
can work but like my friend friends we
can't work anymore like they when I Ryan
you got it don't worry like yourself
with better people going back to your
choices but look II LeBron is built an
empire while playing and obviously it's
a different brand you can't hear Michael
go Michael kept going I'm I'm only
worried about basket but everything else
we'll figure his way out I'm only
worried about last wave everything it
was a better businessman and tourney
that it
LeBron is like doing it now but some
people penalize the brow for it but when
I look at the bran I feel like in the
circumstances that Michael had LeBron
would have done more I couldn't put and
I don't want to know how you feel this
is our field you couldn't put that
Cleveland Cavaliers team with Tristan
Thompson Mozgov and everybody you
couldn't put Michael Jordan on that team
and it go and compete in the NBA Finals
Michael wouldn't even have made it
listen Michael I just I disagree I don't
I don't know about that man I don't know
but I mean I say I think in that sense
what you're talking about right now is I
think in that sense you're taken away
from you know that thing that make
Michael Jordan who he is man like you
know he the Chicago Bulls what your
phone shakin there you go Chicago Bulls
were a joke of a franchise and then when
he got there they immediately started to
do better like like it and then you look
at the trajectory up to six
championships so I disagree in this era
if you want to because you could look
you can move pieces all you want you
could take a chance good what a really
good player got him to the FC cool I
mean Blake Griffin took to the playoff I
mean got swept I understand that but I
think that that guy that LeBron was when
he scored 25 on the Pistons and a
quarter that LeBron that LeBron was who
Jordan was early on in his career you
know when he dropped 60 on the Celtics
you know nobody lost but I understand
that but that's the whole point
I don't disagree that Michael wouldn't
have got his points but I'm saying Eric
he was lost I know but he got his team
there he got his team to that level
tipped in by the way lost to one of the
greatest teams of all time like top five
top five teams of any error was that
Celtics team that dad he scored 16
LeBron would have never been in the
eighth seed he never would have been in
a granite Michael was hurt that year and
you know had a bad will we understand
that but LeBron would not have been in
the eighth seed because he would have
had you
LeBron already under
with phil jackson had to bring to
michael now LeBron didn't that and
that's what we don't print LeBron
understands if I gave him him in him and
fall right and I take over and once I
learn how to take over we're gonna win
where Michael is like listen Kill Bill
Cartwright can't make a layup he ain't
getting about the damn ball for me no
more alright cause everywhere it was to
get them up the two things that these
two different players needed to learn
are different there aren't different
trajectories Michael needed to learn how
to use his teammates LeBron he needed to
learn how to trust his coach and
management he needed somebody I think if
you want to talk about moving chess
pieces LeBron just needed a a coach he
needed a Pat Riley in his life and this
is not any we're not we're talking a
different conversation okay about his
whole career but what I'm saying is
that's where he got in his own way he
got in his own way demanding this
demanding that and this is by the way to
go into this new conversation about this
is and I think that's what's wrong with
the NBA right now you know what you know
what sentence I can't stand and this
only comes from superstars it comes from
the highest paid players I need to do
what's best for my family yo bro you
make him 30-something million dollars a
year your family will be fine in
Minnesota your family will be fine and
whatever until you're 37 then you can
retire and do whatever the hell you want
I that that I think free agency in a way
that it is right now is I just think it
it's set to gain back well you know you
know that's the statement that you can't
really get mad at your family who can
call that Bluff and be like oh I don't
give a damn about your family because
they still live in actually they live in
more fat they actually live in fatter in
like some little town in Oklahoma City
thirty million dollars million you know
or that it does in LA you can't really
glass that statement because the someone
said man
it's your family you didn't say you need
to say gonna say candy like whoa hey
like but whenever someone says he and me
and my family you can't let me forget
you like you can't say that no but it's
just I just think that the way I don't
think this the players how they've taken
this is just a byproduct of the the
owners the owners tried to get control
of the salary cap so they can spread the
money out more I get that I understand
why they had that hard cattle had that
like what max salary but the problem
with a max salary is now that all the
players could be like well I know what
the max salary is so let me just go
wherever I want and get my max salary so
you know you don't look at you know you
don't look at and this is tough this is
a byproduct of the media you don't look
at the owners you know where the Mack
salary comes into play is because the
owners went out and they would get
players and they would they would pay I
think it was big dog Lynn Robinson I
know they would pay him 200 million and
then they want to pay another guy okay
they pay complain but they were their
own biggest wait wait wait wait one I
totally with you see what do people
don't understand is these NBA teams are
not for the most part
this isn't these people's main source of
income it's an Xbox it's it's it's a
it's a it's a it's a little passion
project they wanna win these
billionaires would spend 30 million
dollars a player if they could because
they want to win so the salary cap is in
place to stop them but then what was
happening is like that so in and so the
max salary thing is so they can go okay
look if we're gonna have a salary cap we
don't want to give all our money to one
guy so let's let's make it so we could
give a spread the money out amongst the
teams but then that is backfired on them
too and you wanna you want to hear the
irony so the Commissioner comes up with
a good idea and you know you with your
own team they maintain your bird rights
and your bird rights mean you I can pay
you the most money so you can make 30
million with us or you can sue me 50
million with us or you
can leave and make 30 million you'd be
leaving the money on the table
now some players just went ahead and
said forget the money I don't care I'm
leaving and we've seen that Anthony
Davis could have got a lot more money to
stay with the pelicans but you start
adding in hair laying his brand and all
that yada yada yada we get that just and
at this time to you we're in levels of
money where I know it sounds crazy but
there you go
I'm fine with that too losing that 20
because I'm about to get and check this
out look ruins it so you can also offer
your own player the the mega max right
you know who ruined it because you know
and you know what the mega max is set up
to do so you keep your own players right
they say Kimble Walker comes available
right the idea is you can keep your
all-star point guard here in Charlotte
do you think Charlotte offered him the
mega max you know the whole idea of the
mega max was for you to offer your
player and keep him and lock him in so
the owners get in their own way and when
it comes to players leaving and all I
got to do what's best for me I think was
spun around or missed and I get it like
it's like it's not like just suck it up
and just be there you getting a lot of
money right yeah what's misses you know
who always does who does what's best for
them mr. taine the bra it's the owners
those teams of the only you know the
only and I throw this to you real quick
I want to credit the only one team that
is done was best but a player try to
give him what he deserves and that's the
lottery Los Angeles Lakers with Kobe
Bryant and said I don't care if you not
worth the max I don't care we're not
attracting the free agents which you
have given the bus family in Los Angeles
you are you we just sign on the dotted
line Kobe I don't know you know at the
time at the 20 at the time I thought to
myself once now that if you looked at
Miami and you looked at the Lakers if
you're a free agent you you're gonna go
well i'ma go to the Lakers cuz they
gonna take care of me in the end Miami
they didn't do that
even though that was a better many Pat
Riley thought that was better for
business but he could have paid Dwayne
Wade and he didn't even though Dewayne
ended up coming back there so I know
what you're saying
and
LeBron left - he got frustrated cuz he
want to make certain moves and they were
like now what someone say Laird but I
just think that the free agency the way
is set up right now is killing the game
I just don't I don't like it I I like
the idea of teams I think the teams
should be in more control of the players
I mean I'm just I mean y-you listen
think about Eric do you want to favor
the billionaire or do we want a favor
that's a who came from nothing that's
why we're favoring the billionaires
that's a byproduct that's a byproduct of
the system I understand what you're
saying but the billionaires are
providing this entertainment for the
masses that's how they became
billionaires that's how the players are
becoming rich and all I'm saying is the
product itself is being looked over what
two sides trying to look out for
themselves let me give you my idea let
me give you my idea you can tell me what
you think of it I think they should do
away with free agency in the way that it
is right now and I think it should go
like this if you can't resign your
player then that player at the end of
the year if you can't come to some
negotiation or a trade then that player
then goes into a free agency draft and
at the end of the year you have two
drafts you have the rookie draft and
then you have the free agency draft and
then they end up going wherever to build
some excitement and some intrigue in the
league and make sure that there's there
to just parody you know what I mean or
it's like it's not just six guys going
hey let's play together because we've
always wanted to do that now it just
becomes like a you won't know that you
all know how the owners will mess that
up how are they do it if you think they
tank to get the number one pick what the
hell do you think they would do to get
in the free agency drive why would you
would have teams you would have teams
sending in the entire squad and G
leaguers out there watching the hitter
here's a change demanding that G League
in that in that in that you know the
megamax try what well here's how they
should change that here's how here's I
think they should change that I think
that like what like I think that the
bottom teams like I think that like the
9th seed whoever the 9th seeded
is like that should be the the they
should they should be playing for the
draft pick so let's go then so just make
up play for it
you have seems literally throwing games
to get to the ninth seed third place
it's always something let there have to
be some integrity in the game though you
know blow not know we're saying is but
you know that has to be we got no way to
legislate it you can't legislate it
no no because let's say I'm a third
place team right don't want to play the
sixth place team in the playoffs or but
I want to draw up to the knife seed now
I think you're golden come on if you're
doing that like that's crazy if you're
gonna it will it would if you could get
that would be kind of max player yeah no
no I'm not talking about no no I'm not
talking about the four that I'm not
talking about no no I'm talking about
for the rookie draft I'm saying like the
transition see but that's what stuff
because and that's where you bring up
the best word you just said is integrity
right yeah when you bring up integrity
you would have a team Eric you would
have a team like the Cleveland Cavaliers
per se right when they're doing really
bad right they actually needed the
number one pick in the draft where it
seemed like Philadelphia per se when
they went through their process they
were just dumping dumping players
playing Gigli guys trying to lose they
played really hard but they tried to
lose so that's the give-and-take where
there are teams that kind of like like
Dave like we need it but when you look
back on adapt didn't you but see the
process it was an experiment that didn't
work
I mean who said it didn't mean just cuz
it's not easy
only one team was that I would say once
heard only one team wins a championship
I think that everything that has
happened to that franchise with all the
injuries and everything that has
happened is you just kind of go I mean
you kind of reap what you sow I mean it
just seems like Karma it feels like
Karma you know like they screwed around
with the system a couple of those
players didn't know how to win they
draft it extremely wrong with a couple
others I mean they passed on guys like
Yanis kristaps porzingis we can go down
the list where they missed out on it
they swung and missed and then you look
at them now and and it
give him credit they were even acknow
LeBron was going to la taille was
already set up but they were in play
with calf space to get LeBron was sim as
an in bead that you know and then we
look at that and go man wow that's a
difference maker you can't take the
freedom from the players Eric and I get
what you want is parody but let's be
honest early parody but I just think
that the way the system is set up now
people we I just you don't want to see
us in like that Golden State thing hat
should happen again cuz that's where
that's the lack of integrity on the
players part in that in that sense but
Eric here it is let's just be honest
damn straight up with everything Golden
State was good for the league and I say
good for the league in the sense where
yeah you knew the cards were stacked we
wanted to see a competitive championship
we didn't get that and that really stunk
but that's gonna be really really hard
to see again but second reason I say
it's gonna be hard to see again is and I
say Golden State was good for the league
on the other end is because thing about
Eric Golden State was the story every
single day the ratings were higher than
ever
whether they were good whether they were
bad it was something to watch the by
Larry the leave me let me let me step in
on this right here so I grew I agree
with you because I think that when you
have a dynasty it's good for the league
if you have a villain you have
somebody's people trying to conquer I
get you but here's the thing about it
though and this is where I must say
something about LeBron James Golden
State is the story but they aren't the
same type of story without LeBron James
who LeBron James that's what I'm trying
to say is he would he is so great that
he that we don't realize that we were
hoping he could do it when he had no
chance back okay he had no chance now
here's the thing too I'm so mad at my
clippers that they didn't win that year
in any way the the um that first year we
go to state alright the first year they
didn't play one starting point guard in
the Western Conference because they were
all injured alright every single
starting point guard in the West was
injured going into the playoffs that
they played against then they get to the
champ
ship Kevin Love and Kyrie Irving go down
they loses six the Cleveland he almost
wins like we're we're shown we're seeing
greatness personified with LeBron James
taken nobody to the promised land
against this fantastic team that where
everybody's talking about now what a
great team they lose the next year I
mean they'll go to stay wins the next
year the 73 win team loses to LeBron
James then after that they get Kevin
Durant and it's a wrap but what I do
what I do what I really have a problem
with now is that going to state OKC
battle that they were going back and
forth I wanted to see that for years to
come
gone that that Celtics Cleveland cuz
that game seven against the Celtics in
the last Finals the LeBron that game was
so fantastic it was just like compelling
that's what the league's now missing
that's that's what the league was
missing with all this moving around and
stuff it's like building up that that
rivalry building up that like let's go
for it I mean I just think that and then
when they go okay so look Kevin Durant
goes well I need a championship and I
need to like you know be remembered that
way I'm as just as good as all these
players let me go get that that thing
and look what happened it just let me
throw this to you too when the Lakers
went out in acquired Shaquille O'Neal
along with Kobe Bryant and swept the
playoffs that's as much of but now I get
it it's not the same as a 70 72 in team
getting where we're getting that never
ride away bro that didn't happen right
away they couldn't get past San Antonio
three years in a row but I'm saying it
was a little more homegrown it wasn't
like they just inserted a guy on there
but there was still the level of
dominance where as an LA Laker fan yeah
I was whooping and hollering but if I
miss Morton or whatever I'm like it's in
the process though it seems like it's in
the it seems like you know there's like
even if it's false there's a feeling of
this was done in a way that everybody
had a chance to do it
this is what I'm saying this is what I'm
saying I rather the teams have to
maneuver to get Shaquille O'Neal rather
than Shaquille O'Neal going I'm out and
I'm going to the best team in the league
I don't like that but [__] but think
about this hold on Shaq was in talks
with Jerry Buss and kind of had it in
the works
he knew all those trades don't just come
out of thin air of course was the kind
of stone to show up and he made his way
to get there we didn't just and then you
got to think of a team like LA the
Lakers after you kissed Shaq and Kobe
you handpick you can Rick Fox for free
you get Glen Rice you you get these guys
turning down other money so I just think
it's a part of the draw I think if we
didn't see Kevin Durant compete against
those guys and join them you gotta chalk
it up to the game and I just believe
that the coaching in Oklahoma City and
the way that team was built frustrated
Kevin Durant to no end where he just
wants to play good basketball now thank
God but thank God do you think that
wasn't going on during the Jordan error
cuz imagine if he would have been like a
Fergie I can't beat I don't like how
we're being coached against the Pistons
so you know what I'm gonna do I'm just
gonna leave and I'm gonna go join the
Pistons but listen if they had lost and
they played good basketball guys hit
shots the ball popped around the horn
and you know it was equal opportunity
and they just lost because going state
made shots but he was like seven for 30
one night they love you but you got to
hear this I'm looking at going does not
look at numbers Liz Lucas style Kevin
Durant when I competed against them
I remember at times we would throw three
guys at him and for him to get his
bucket he just had that it was like rest
of the team go over here all right
Russell you go rest of the team go over
there Kevin Durant you go and score it
was bad basketball and it finally wore
on him and then you're playing against
someone not as talented as you but
they're moving the ball they share it
there running sacks you like man I want
to be a part of good basketball I'm not
gonna blame Katie I think it was just it
was just read even if listen but real
real stinking toy even if you had a team
that tried to stack the eyes together it
wouldn't work and the only people really
with that type of power are the KDS and
they know the LeBron Jameses that's what
we are and I know I totally agree with
you on that man but that's why they need
to be they need to be protected from
themselves is what I'm saying you know
they need to be protected from this
stuff because when it saw the guy again
when it's all said and done like during
the time he's raising the trophies doing
this thing and he looks like oh look I'm
king of the world and he is a no doubt
top basketball player like you know like
Kevin Durant has the talent to be in the
go conversation if he like you know
let's say he gets like five more
championships are you gonna be like oh
[__] he's just as good or if not better
than so-and-so God you know what I mean
so what I'm saying though is that but
those kind of guys need to be protected
from themselves too because they think
like that too I mean his whole thing was
like I'm great I want to show I'm great
so instead of like doing it with the
people that he was with he said I need
to show I'm great right now let me let
me get out of here and it's like I I
agree look I don't I don't knock the guy
for it
because he used this system to his
advantage I'm saying I'm I don't like
the system that's what I'm saying they
shouldn't be allowed to do that that's
what I'm saying but I don't begrudge
them for doing it look you you have the
max contract you NBA players don't even
need a agent anymore you know they could
just be like here's my lawyer I know I
could only make 25 million that's the
max give me the max and they can
negotiate from there a lot you hear a
lot of players become their own agent
and just have a lawyer now instead of
having that you know so the owners set
that in place and they're getting they
reap what they sow so at some point
though that's gonna have to be a rehaul
or retool they're gonna have to somehow
find a way and especially coming off
this because like you know and to get
off that discussion when do you think
we're gonna come back to play basketball
do you think that we're gonna finish
this season I'm really torn and you know
torn between two sides and we I think we
have to obviously monitor I know
couple of these states plan on you know
loosening up on how things are handling
we see numbers Texas already done it 20
times in in restaurants and these part
numbers are gonna rise up or they're
gonna lower or how it's gonna be but but
here's the reality you have one stand
point where Eric let's make no mistake
you have billions of dollars probably
trillions swirling around the NBA on
those games being played out so the one
thing if I'm ESPN I'm turn on whoever
hot damn they are fighting feverishly to
get the league back now obviously safe
and sound but you had the other side of
the team's going well I was first placed
in the West or the Eastern Conference
and let's say Charlotte's been working
their guys out but we haven't been
working out you know this year is gonna
be a wash this new reveal and we we
fought everything for nothing so let's
just call it because the worst thing is
an executive you won't know what you get
fired if your team doesn't win a
championship and you look at kolben and
go is it my fault that that you know you
know Anthony Davis wasn't working out
and running sprints in his driveway I
can't control that you know the hair but
then if I seen again again it seemed at
the same way you go call the season but
then I feel bad for us someone like
LeBron James this is it
exactly I don't I don't know if next
year he gonna you know that that Cliff
comes quick for a basketball player yeah
because of the physicality of the sport
yeah ask our players to me are the best
athletes in the world because of what
they have to do on the court and to be
that physically to be 6 7 to 10 with 4%
body fat and have to run up and down the
court and bang with those type of I mean
it's just it's unprecedented
I'm you know I feel bad for him but I
just look here's the problem let's say
they find a way to come back like they
they want to do that fight Island and
UFC you go to an island test everybody
nobody could leave everybody's good
let's fight here's a problem with the
NBA let's say they like they were
talking about maybe taking over Vegas
you know each each teams in a hotel
maybe they can have their families in
the hotels and like you know you lock it
down great it takes is all it takes is
one yeah but all it takes is one
it takes one Gobert and seven people are
infected and then then what do you do
you have to shut the league down for two
weeks for just that team but then that
player sluggish because they were sick
or you know so I just think it would
have to be it would have to be like
state level government level security
where yes I thought you step out your
room and you get tested every day this
room saying we sprained out but you know
what listen when there's billions of
dollars from around this back you can do
it yeah you could walk through a little
a little Sanitation booth before you go
in
yeah you can you can do before you go to
the game don't got it let's go don't got
it but and here's the thing too I feel
about the NBA is that I don't like if
they ever does come back it can't be in
empty stadiums but if you be in high
school gyms because it looks better like
you if you're playing the game in a bit
it looks empty that that looks wack oh
but you play if you play like in a small
then we can still get that sense of
what's happening wean them you know
you've got a trillion dollars they may
have the fans go to a site and they can
cheer remotely and we hear the fans
cheer or more actually or actually
virtual reality and then like you know
everybody has an avatar that's in the
stands yeah they playing on a rain
screen monitor you watch from your house
and you see they you know they can have
a hundred-foot LCD you know that where
you see that mean a listen no but it's
just what I'm saying is like they can
like pump the sound into the stadium for
the players like everybody had at home
has to press their spacebar to cheer or
whatever it is you know you know there's
ways to do that kind of stuff 2020
brother that's what I'm saying you look
the look of it it can't be in stadiums
and that's why I don't think football is
gonna come back and there's more money
on the line with football but that's
gonna look stupid like football in in a
in a ninety thousand seat arena empty
like like I mean you just gotta change
the camera angles you just can't show
that you know the confetti
you can put confetti everywhere or or uh
you know they got Manning when they got
mannequins they put mannequins like what
if that's what it is everybody buys like
your season seat is sitting like with a
mannequin that has a GoPro on it and and
that's your that's your and you could
you can move it and that's how you're at
the game I don't know it's just I just I
just had a visual of seeing you in your
seat at the Clippers games I was
laughing cuz I'm like every time I
looked over at you during the game you
had something wild to say like there was
some Joker I'm getting liftoff while I
walk around like like it was like a
moment were like somebody gets dunked on
and we catch the eyes like oh wait yeah
you know what you know it's a funny last
story funny story though I was like
could I go I was going when I had those
seats with Adam Devine you know Adam and
so we there was a game we they were
playing OKC
hey Russell Westbrook he did something
and Adam and I got up and we said
something to him he looked over at us
and gave us a death stare that we both
were like what damn what's wrong and
then even one of the Clippers people
came over to us and said yo what'd you
say to Russell like that got cheap by
the way in closing that's the type of
guy that needs better coaching that's
the type of guy that has that thing that
has that he has been saying he's got
that thing that he needs somebody like
he's like a stallion and he's somebody
to go whoa whoa Brian I mean he needs to
be somebody to hone it in and then let
it loose at the right particular time
you know and by the way and even last
last thing is that one of that thing
about that Jordan documentary that I saw
Phil Jackson needs more credit facts
Phil Jackson is way more credible not
coaching the last year you want to fire
me about to screw this up yeah he just
just how he managed those personalities
the heat he made the greatest player to
date
okay just he still is man until you know
who Michael Jordan he made him take all
of that just tremendous brain
physicality and he mold
he guided it he said we need to do this
trust me and the dude did some of these
other great players haven't had somebody
in there in their life like that and
that's what's held them back LeBron
James included yeah that's that's that's
that's what are you yeah I agree I agree
shoot LeBron LeBron Pat Riley might not
have been there but Pat Roddy was there
and well abroad learned from Pat who who
got had spoke his foe is Pat and by the
way figured out how to win he said oh
this is how you win all right cool and
by the way by the way I understand why
LeBron went back to Cleveland but he
shouldn't have and that's where the free
agency messes things up like that's
that's what I'm saying he should have
stayed in Miami I get why he left I
crazy no I get it he needed to do that I
understand that's what I'm saying I'm
not mad I'm not completely mad about it
I understand why I would have left too
if I was in his shoes but I'm like but
like but like again even I don't even
think he should have went to Miami
really I mean clearly he had the finest
Phil Jackson bro I agree yeah Jackson he
didn't get he didn't get all he my
biggest point a real talk Kevin Durant
was like damn I'm not being direct the
bran head up by myself
I need these boys hey see he's another
guy that got it he said he's the cat
okay you know what he's actually a
cautionary tale against my argument if
you think about it because Kevin
Durant's a cautionary tale of life yo
it's one thing to be loyal it's one
thing to like work within the system but
when the system ain't doing anything for
you you need to start to step out of the
system and he didn't he did it too late
he didn't you late because to me listen
the reason why Tim we could keep talking
is fine the reason why Tim Duncan is the
greatest powerful ever is
because he was one of the very few of a
handful and not even a full handful of
power forwards who were the best power
forward on the team best player on the
team and won the championship that list
is small in the last 40 years where the
power fort is the best player on the
team because even kevin garnett when he
won in South with the Celtics I argue to
say to Paul Pierce was the best player
on that team you know I you and I mean
this with no disrespect and I want to
make sure this term is used the correct
way Kevin Garnett to me Kevin Garnett
Scottie Pippen Anthony Davis greatest
role players of all time but you know
absolute megastars well when I say role
player I only say in the term of that's
not gonna be the guy to demand to take
the last shot can he hit the last shot
yes yes but those guys they block shots
they rebound they pass they fill the
stat sheet but they're not necessarily
the LeBron the magic the Kareem and then
when I say role player please do not
take that anything like like bad or in
horrible taste or disrespect those are
mega stars top 50 greatest players ever
I will put those three guys on a list
with Scotty Kevin Garnett Anthony Davis
in a mold in my mind of greatest role
players ever
all right color wise I always think of
him like if you had military terms I
always think of him like it like you
know they have this tremendous skill
like a sniper you know like a person
eken you know shoot from like a thousand
yards away and hit hit up dime you know
that person has a specific skill but
they need their troops they need people
around them to help them be able to do
that and there's players that are
tweeners in between that and those kind
of guys to me are like I think Cara
Garnett was one of those type guys who
was a superstar but he needed people you
know I mean and I look this I think Kobe
Bryant was the same way too
I think Kobe Bryant was a kind of guy
that he had to have
a Shack a paga saw uh air with him to
complement what he does I was saying
this is like Kobe's gonna take the last
shot
Garnett may not prints per se and that's
not a knock to him at all he just played
his role Kobe is like I am the role but
I just think you know what I was looking
at you ever watch all the smoke I love
that podcast no I haven't seen it all
you got to see with uh with uh what's
his name Barnes and why am I forgetting
their damn names Steven Jackson Steven
Jackson and Matt Barnes they have a
podcast called all the smoke it's long
it's a Showtime podcast then you gotta
watch that they had they've had Kobe on
there they've had Kevin Durant and they
and and their players are more free with
them they just open up and say things
and I don't think they really want want
to be public you know to me it's a great
podcast you gotta check that one now but
like you know that that's where you see
you know Kobe Bryant was talking about
how Kevin Durant was almost a Laker like
back it's you know instead of when he
was gonna leave he would almost became a
Laker and even Kevin Durant talks about
that on his thing that he was he almost
became a Laker and that would have been
like tremendous magic Kobe Kobe and
carnet together is uh even better than
Shaq and Kobe because they would have
fit he would have been his Pippen yeah
even though even though I think that
Shaq I think when we look at shot I
don't think she had gets enough credit
either for how just completely done III
went to the Lakers games I went to the
Laker games I had season tickets that
year that it was Gary Payton Kahl Malone
and Kobe and Shaq
you know and I remember why they lost it
was Scott Williamson injured Karl Malone
and they were never the same after that
that he injured he jumped out at a Karl
Malone shot hurt Karl Malone's me and
for the rest of the season Karl Malone
was trying to recover from that I'll
never forget that but anyway I just
think that when I was watching the game
when have you ever seen Shaq play live
you looking you realize this dude is
fouled
every single play no exaggeration he's
being elbowed and
hit and pushed and and it's like damn
and still that dominant he's somebody
that got in his own way to man if he had
the ire to tiger he'll be the greatest
player ever
oh yeah yeah they get forget Jordan
forget about all of them forget all of
them
what a guys just seven three four
percent body fat back attic check this
Phil this is where Phil gave his first
bit of bad advice Phil went to Shaq and
said Shaq lift weights get bigger get
stronger I want you to be as strong as
you can be but if he had been saying
Shaq work on your touch around the rim
get nimble get fast we gonna do this for
20 years
yeah but the guy I mean I don't know if
he says himself that he wished he would
even work out in the offseason if he
tells you you know eat burgers and lift
weights
you ain't worried about running and
conditioning and jumping and running hey
Lane cool the game is easy can reserve
and result of three and result was you
know three championships it could have
been ten I mean and that's why I'm not
that ESPN conversation between Shaq and
Kobe was so great imagine like like
you're Shaq and Kobe is trying to tell
you go work on your game and he's like
bro I can turn and dunk on anybody and
these are growth these are in the night
like I just show up the camp and I do it
like how you gonna tell that guy to work
out how do you know that gotta work out
oh well I wish he would have listened I
think he thinks that too in the end I
think he might look back and be like no
no I done this in in certain terms we
talk about business Shaq won at business
yeah like I don't want to say life
because that's it that's it I'm not the
judge of that
and Kobe won at basketball but Shaq is
gonna be relevant and making money for
the next thousand Shaq is bigger listen
hold on he's a blue Easley Jack is
bigger off the court that he was on in
2020 he's a very rare
name absolutely at this point I'm yeah I
guess just like Charles Barkley it took
a while oh yeah
Charles too yet but it took a while for
Kobe to go let me like Kobe still big
from basketball obviously he's one of
the greatest players of all time
but I'm saying Shaq just made a choice
that said I would be relevant forever
yeah he positioned himself post
basketball just already thought we were
gonna be relevant forever yeah man yeah
man well look dude we've been talking
for over an hour and I love this I love
you know this is great
anytime bro I really appreciate you
inside I love watching you like get
riled up on all these debate shows I
hope you get I hope I listen I hope
Sports comes back so not just for sports
but for people like yourself
you know what I mean it's like this is
like it you don't realize how a shutdown
affects so many people the trickle-down
is is astronomical it's just yeah the
effect of it has just been terrible for
a lot of people even even at the highest
level all the way down to the people
that work in the stadiums
I have a friend of mine who's been
working at Staples Center for the last
15 years you don't mean and it's like
that's all gone I'm talking about
concerts you know so it's like there's
no revenue for that so it's like all
from the top all the way down to the
littlest people this is effective so I
hope you staying safe I hope your family
it looks like you're your family's well
I don't know why you wives that you had
that Rihanna picture on the wall right
there wait wait you ain't [__] you ain't
just just FYI are you a [__] this is
supposed to be cultured man we got oh
it's cold oh I see and I wait wait is it
I see how it's like right near you right
next to your picture is that like a
fantasy you had I know when you put it
up he was like let me flip me honor
right here next to me
I had like a contest for artists listen
man you want to get your stuff on the
wall if I was gonna do it she'd be in a
bikini on top of mine it's a compromise
this man you take care and thanks for
taking the call and I'll see you soon
and I hit you up on this episode
releases and I really appreciate you
coming on a man appreciate you brother
you too man take care
[Music]